getting back to the whole
um you know going through the recovery
and like the
comeback like what's the strategy for
you with the comeback
um well i mean right basically
my comeback is in the hands of the
surgeons that are going to be putting me
back together and their instructions
of what i can and can't do um i did get
the green light on june 1st to start
going back to the gym so what are we at
the 24th 25th now yeah so
yeah i can i've been back in the gym for
about three weeks now
uh lifting lightly i'm starting as we
talked before i was eating crap and now
i'm starting to clean up my diet
um and it's just be as healthy as
possible for this next surgery
uh for a better chance of it being
successful because there is a chance
that it could go wrong
as with any surgery yeah um and it's
just be
be healthy be as healthy as possible and
get back into my routine of going to the
gym and doing cardio and
just you know i'm documenting everything
all the ups and downs of
of what i go through over the next
couple of months um
is going to be on film so you had this
um
you know this uh moment where you kind
of mentioned like these
you know uh you know weaker guys and
i've seen you met you know mentioned
in videos it's like just go to the gym
man like just stop stop complaining
about stuff don't be a whim just go and
lift bro
and a lot of guys laugh at that they
sometimes mock you when you say that and
yeah i've gotten into this pattern
lately
where i get messages from it's usually
younger guys like in their teens or
maybe early
early 20s and they're like hey man you
know i like everything you do and i want
to be mentored by you you know what do i
need to do like i'll make your coffee
i'll wipe your ass in whatever it is
you know it's going to take and i always
start with you know what show me that
you can do 30 push-ups 10 chin-ups and
skip rope for three minutes straight
start with that and almost always these
guys can't
do basic stuff you know like fundamental
basics that would improve your
uh confidence your positivity and your
outlook in life and
get all like the endocrine markers
firing up and making you feel better and
all that like
like i'm big on that
and i think it's really important that
if you want to be successful and you
want to get something done in the world
like you've got to have
a competent body and mindset to do that
in
what are your thoughts on how lifting
and working out and not necessarily
being like a full-on hardcore gym bro
right but
do you think that that played a big part
in your success as a guy
oh yeah because i mean anytime you would
see me do those videos
uh in the car you know the more popular
ones that where i'm in the car screaming
is either right before i'm going into
the gym and i'm just
doped up on all this pre-workout or or
it's post-workout and i just got done
with a workout and
i mean anybody who's gone to the gym and
and actually put in the effort to to do
a workout you don't have to be big you
don't have to be jacked but you people
know when they
they've had a good workout you feel
different like you feel
super confident you feel inspired you
feel
like you could take on the world just
because of like you said all the
endorphins and everything running
through your body
um that was a big part of the character
um
is is being in the gym or around the gym
obviously you know i was all jacked up
and everything but
yeah that that definitely helped my my
mental state to create
content and whatever came to my mind i
would just spit out and it was always
surrounded
around the gym and the earlier videos
especially
every video was whatever is going wrong
in
your life whatever is happening whether
it's a challenge on tick tock or
instagram or whether it's this or
whether it's that
screw all that go to the gym screw all
that go to the gym and and
people dug it
you